my mom will write love you instead of i  love you and i'll go and i'll be  depressed for a week i'll be like my  mother doesn't love me  i need the eyes she didn't put the idea  it's such a like yeah i love you like i  don't matter to you if you put i love  you that means i as a human being i am  internalizing my love for you and i'm  packaging it in such a way that i'm  writing it in the language that we've  been given by god i love you just love  you you might as well just say [ __ ] you  it's the same thing really you bring  that stock  pimp i love you is a bit more formal and  direct than love you i can agree with  that sentiment but i cannot agree that  love you coming from someone who loves  you is any different than saying i love  you we're going to agree to disagree  because i love you oh i love you  again this is a podcast with two grown  men who are both straight talking back  to back about the difference between  love you and i love you and their  jewelry